[Music]
hello and welcome back to
chess openings explained my name is
caleb denby
uh and today i'm going to be walking you
through one of the last lines of the
caro con
that i have not yet covered uh so
it is going to be the fantasy variation
today
uh the fantasy variation a name with a
very fun name
or one opening line with a very fun name
and it does look rather threatening at
first glance from the white pieces
so it's definitely one worth taking a
look at here it is not the most popular
response
to the keracon but it is one of the main
lines i would consider
it so why don't we just take a look here
i've got a game between
michaelo olexienko and sam shankland of
course sam former us
champion now with the black pieces of
course the game starts with e4
c6 d4 d5 and now uh
so far we've covered a variety of moves
here from white
the three big ones are knight c3 or
knight d2 we'll kind of
uh both those in together uh e5
or e takes d5 these are the three main
responses by white
and f3 is the fantasy variation and it
is the most often kind of overlooked
line i would say from
the carol repertoire here of the main
third moves that that white can reply
with and now there are a variety of ways
of playing
the way i'm going to recommend is kind
of most in line with the
the classic carol philosophy being that
you want to develop this bishop outside
of the pawn chain
before playing the move e6 that being
said the most common move here is in
fact e6
going for a more kind of triangle
defense
setup and this is a very very solid way
of playing it's not a bad way of playing
at all
because it's forced white to go into a
slightly weird line
against uh something like the triangle
and
so if you want to play lines like this
you're more than welcome to but the way
i'm going to recommend is with d
takes e4 and f takes e4
and now at first glance it looks like
you give up a pretty strong
center here to your opponent with the
white pieces
the advantage to this though is that
white has sort of overextended
in the center already and so because of
that
black can also make a very strong claim
in the center immediately
because white has spent so many tempi
getting these two pawns out
black wastes no time and immediately
plays the move e5
and this is going to be the the crux of
the fantasy fantasy variation line that
i'm recommending for black it's going to
be
this pawn right here on the e5 square
a slightly outdated term uh in chess
principles chess strategy one that you
may not have heard is the term
of the strong point defense and that
term kind of applies
to this line in the keracon so we're
gonna see a variety of games
but they really all revolve around
around this e5 square
when your opponent has uh these strong
central pawns like this
the most common way that players lose
games is they play a slightly worse move
let's say move like e6
and then later on in the game
just for example both players develop
their pieces a little bit
knight d7 bishop d3 knight f6 later on
in the game
the enemy ends up pushing something like
e5 or
d5 to open up just a ton of lines take a
ton of central space
and kind of roll over the opponent here
and the idea
with e5 in this opening line is you
don't allow this e5 move from white to
ever
happen and if white never gets this e5
move
in well then the the open lines are not
going to ever open
and this central majority isn't actually
going to be worth all that much
white doesn't find a good way to use it
so this is the strong point defense that
black is using here with e5
so e5 knight f3 now
bishop g4 of course is the the classic
caro
way to play now bishop c4 is the most
common way to play by white and really
white goes for more or less a very
similar setup
in almost every line there is one very
interesting line with the move bishop d3
that we're going to take a
take a look at a little bit later but
this
obviously not bishop d3 here rather
first c3 i think and then bishop d3 to
make sure that d4
stays protected but uh for the moment
we're going to look at bishop c4 first
now here it is very important that you
play
knight d7 who in the chat can find a
tactic for white after the move
knight f6 perhaps the most natural move
here who in the chat can find a tactic
who sees the tactic
so yes as it sits has said the tactic
begins with bishop takes f7 now after
king takes f7
there's this move knight takes c5 when
unfortunately
for black this bishop is defended once
uh but being defended once is not going
to be enough here so knight takes c5 and
bishop takes f7 that's why
knight d7 is the only move for black now
if the same tactic is tried well we have
this e5 square covered
so of course if knight takes c5 knight
takes e5 covers the bishop
and if knight g5 well simply queen takes
g5
is a winning desperado for black of
course
black at the end of the day is going to
end up up a piece
compared to white so knight d7 uh the
move here
have to be on the lookout do not play
knight f6
you will lose horribly knight d7 first
always remember okay king side castles
for black
and now knight gf6 uh sorry kingside
castles for white knight gf6 for black
and now the move c3 is likely going to
come on the board
and we'll talk about some move order
tricks by white in the next game but for
the moment
with this move order by white the most
common move order you can just play the
move bishop d6 here
like i said it's the strong point
defense so we're not really going to
play a move like bishop e7
in most of these lines because we want
to hold our strong point on e5 it's all
about defending
this e5 pawn so bishop e7
probably not going to be good enough
here for black not defending the square
enough time so bishop d6
now bishop g5 is a very common way to
play by white this is
more or less the main plan for white
white goes bishop g5 and then we'll see
later
wants to increase the pressure on this
king's side
at a later date black can simply castle
now knight bd2 is a natural developing
move
and uh the kind of weird move
queen c7 by black so once again
i can't stress this enough it's all
about controlling the e5 square
in this line for black just
an example of some travesties that might
happen if you play a move like bishop e7
let's say move like bishop e3 castles
knight bd2 black or white can just play
very simply let's say a move like a5
comes on the board
well all of a sudden uh let's see
uh eventually let's say queen e1
um and okay let's just say black waste
to tempo for example if
if you ever lose this e5 pawn if you
ever
allow white to kind of crash through on
this square
then it's it's going to just be game
over uh that's that's the point i'm
trying to get across so that's why
we're using all of our pieces to defend
e5 so i didn't give the best counter
example there
but just trust me it's all about e5 here
all about e5
now queen e1 from white is the main way
to play you just simply want to get this
queen out to h4
uh and now sam in this game shows
a pretty interesting way to reorganize
the pieces here
white has now of course broken the pin
on this knight
and so black has a couple options for
what he wants to do he can try and leave
this bishop on g4
it's going to be a little bit shaky on
this square due to threats from the
queen
so in the game sam simply chose the move
bishop h5
trying to reroute this bishop all the
way back to g6 now
there are a couple different ways you
can play here a couple different things
have been tried
the move b5 comes to mind we'll see b5
occur later in this
game the move h6 is actually also
playable and this is a pretty
interesting way
of dealing with these sort of problems
on the king side
because it forces white to make a
decision of bishop h4
or bishop e3 now bishop h4 i think that
black is
is actually going to be quite happy with
the way that things have gone
because you no longer have to worry
about this threat of queen h4 putting
more pressure on this knight
but i think bishop e3 does actually give
black a little bit more
to worry about because you're always
going to have to be on the lookout for
this move queen h4
and any kind of sacrifice here on h6
it's actually going to be
well worth considering for white so i
don't really like this move h6 it just
gives the opponent
a few too many sacrificing chances on
the king's side i think
it's just a bit too weak and in giving
your opponent this this hook as i like
to say
so bishop h5 seems normal
now queen h4 was played in this game
adding more pressure to this knight on
f6 and now simply bishop g6 this is the
reroute
that sam has completed now in the game
oleg cienko played the slightly strange
looking move king h1
and who in the chat knows why
king h1 was played or has some idea as
to why king h1
was alexianco's choice here how does it
make any sense
why is the strong point defense
considered outdated um
sorry i kind of misspoke it's not an
outdated way of playing
it's just you don't hear this term too
often anymore um the only place i've
really seen it is like
books written in in the 80s uh for some
reason it
this kind of term has just kind of been
lost i think i have heard some players
use it but
so the term itself i think is what's
outdated not not the strategy you'll
you'll see quite often actually
specifically in like roy lopez positions
this e4 e5
uh structure is is black's main way of
playing and and white still gets this d4
in but black creates this kind of strong
point on e5
to to slow down the the play
so we can move the d pawn and to prevent
queen b6 so you guys
pretty much pretty much have it here
knight g1 is
is not really going to be the idea uh
white
doesn't really want to spend all this
time retreating this knight it's true
that it does add
attackers to f6 but we'll see white has
a better way of doing that
as he played in the game so it is very
much just to prevent these lines with
queen b6
and more specifically to prevent queen
b6 after this d-pawn
moves out of the way uh so again if this
d-pawn
ends up moving then queen b6 is going to
come on the board with with pretty good
effect
so uh in the game rook ae8 was
sam shanklin's choice he's trying to spy
this e4 pawn
uh kind of an x-ray attack through this
pawn now
black is going to be the one threatening
to take on d4
of course it gives up our strong point a
little bit but it's well worth it if we
take away
our opponent's central majority we we
don't really need the strong point
if we kill the center right so rook a e
eights
rook ae1 was the natural follow-up by
olek st
oleksienko simply supporting this pawn
further
uh and now we do see the move b5 from
sam shankland just gaining a little bit
of queen side space
bishop b3 and now this is the position
where i had to stop and analyze for
quite a bit
i think this is more or less the the
critical position for
this fantasy variation line for both
sides here
this is really the most natural way of
playing for white and the most natural
way of playing for black
you could argue that the move king h1
was a little bit slow
but we're going to take a look at what
happens if d takes e5 occurs immediately
and a lot of those lines end up
failing to things like queen v6 checks
so in my opinion king h1 is a perfectly
fine move
by by white so
now it's kind of decision time for black
we've kind of been delaying making a
decision about what to do
by making kind of threats that improve
our pieces for example rook 88 created a
threat to e4
b5 created a threat to the bishop and
before that we had threats of queen b6
uh winning b2 but now white has sort of
dealt with with all of those threats and
we can't really make
any more immediate threats so what's
going to happen
if we just play a normal looking move
for example if the move a6
comes on the board a perfectly fine
strengthening move on the queen side
supporting the b5 pawn what is white
going to do
um i i'll let you at home
try and come up with an answer but i'm
not going to wait too long on this one
yes hello to tarquin clark of course i
do remember you
from some previous lectures uh but okay
what white is going to do
is take on e5 this is kind of the crux
of white's play black has built up the
strong point
on e5 and white has been trying to
break it down and it hasn't really
seemed
like that's what white has been doing
but the way white
went about doing this is by attacking
this f6
knight so by attacking this f6 knight
we're overworking now
this knight on d7 and forcing black to
make some concessions
to keep this e5 pawn so now for example
this has actually been played in a
couple games in the lead chess database
not by
super high level players and they all
played knight takes e5 allowing this
bishop takes f6
g takes f6 and now actually
in both of these games black ended up
winning but i think after the move
knight d4
black actually does have quite a few
problems here to try and solve so i
don't like this way of playing just
slowly
because i do think that uh this is a
legitimate threat from
from white now of course black could
take this back with the bishop instead
but uh while i do think this is okay for
black i'm always hesitant
to give up the bishop pair like this
with the bishop pair
off the board i do think white actually
does have a little bit of something to
play for for example knight f3
queen c5 and already e5 and and
these lines that we weren't so happy
about uh being opened are starting to
to kind of come apart now knight d5
could come on the board
and i really do think this is a
perfectly playable position
for black i just think it might be a
little bit more comfortable
for white not saying white has a huge
advantage here but white does have this
central space and with the bishop pair
black is going to have to be very
careful or else he could fall into a
significantly worse
position so all of that
is to say our opponent really has made a
threat here with d
takes e5 uh and so there's a couple
different ways you can meet this threat
there's the way that sam shanklin played
and then there's the way that i'm
actually going
to recommend so sam played the move
knight h5
and this is another one of those lines
that uh is going to get into a playable
position
for black it just gets a little bit
complex
along the way so if you're perfectly
fine with that i think knight h5
is a a totally fine move that sam
shanklin came up with in
this game the other move that i'm going
to recommend is actually the move
c5 here and this move c5 is
a pretty natural break for black in
these positions
um in my practical games i actually
rarely
get to this type of position because
in my experience the white players kind
of don't always
fully know what what they're doing if
i'm 100 honest with you
they play some strange stuff so it's
good to remember this c5 break this is a
good freeing move
for black now if white plays the move d5
we're actually quite happy about this
with the black pieces we're going to
break through a c4 now
this bishop has to get out of the way
and then the space on the queen side
is going to be very good for black and
in the meantime
white's pawns are kind of permanently
locked down in the center here
this d-pawn is technically a protected
past pawn
but it's not going to be entirely useful
for
excuse me for white and then sam
shanklin's move knight h5 would be a
perfectly fine follow-up
to this line so i like this move
c5 i'll talk a little bit more about
those lines
now i guess yeah we'll stick with these
lines and get back to the game
the critical line of course is still d
takes e5 this is the line
that is critical so what's different
here from the line that i showed with a6
well here after knight takes c5 i do
think this is the best way of playing
bishop takes f6 g takes f6
note that queen takes f6 might be a
little bit premature because
moves like knight d3 are going to come
on the board moves like c4 can also come
on the board
moves like knight takes f3 when this
pawn is a little bit awkward to defend
might also come on the board just for
example knight takes f3
g takes f3 is the only way to keep this
pawn
and then a move like bishop e7 is
already highlighting that this queen
is a little bit stuck over here it has
to come all the way to a6 there's
actually no other
safe square for this queen and then
moves like c4
bishop c2 and even like queen f4
or actually i guess this pawn's hanging
so like rook b8 and the fact is this
queen is just totally out of play
over here on a6 so queen takes f6 a
little bit of a mistake
instead though you would probably see g
takes f6
and then some other move here for whites
and the point of my play is basically
i'm getting the c4 move in
and after c4 the d3 square is always
going to be a nice target for me
and i'm going to have some play on on
the queen side here
you do get this uncomfortable pawn
structure
with f6 and h7
or sorry f6 and f7 and h7 of course
but you get play on the e pawn you get
play on the queen side and i think this
is a perfectly fine way of playing for
black
now if you don't like the look of those
lines then probably the way that sam
played is your best bet
knight h5 doesn't allow this bishop
takes f6 g takes f6 business
okay so knight h5 played in the game d
takes e5 is still really the only try
for white
note that we would always meet the move
d5 with c5
well i guess not always sometimes you
can actually take this pawn
but c5 and c4 is is a pretty nice
structure for black as i previously
stated so net h5 takes e5
knight takes e5 knight takes e5 bishop
takes e5
and now knight f3 from black sorry from
white
and i do think now that this position
from sam is
the simplest way for black to play and
probably it's just going to be
the the easiest equality that that
you're going to find
uh the downside to the way that sam
played is
either one here you have to play the
move bishop f6
in order to keep your your bishop pair
or trade off your bishop for white's
bishop rather than the knight
and in doing so you do give up control
of this e5 square
or your other option is just to continue
play on the queen side with a move like
a5 so you get playing the queen side but
in return
white does get your bishop pair here on
e5 and i actually do like this way of
playing
a little bit better for example a5
knight takes e5
either queen or rook takes is perfectly
fine
and now white might reroute this bishop
hitting this knight
on h5 and you might see the move h6 come
on the board
to avoid dying okay so h6 bishop c1
and now rook fe-8 and the point for
black here i think this is a really
comfortable position
for black is you just have this really
extraordinarily weak pawn
on e4 and white has two bishops but not
a lot to do with them
basically white's pieces are just going
to be tied down to defending this pawn
and black i think is is actually just a
slight bit better a slight bit better
it's hard to
really like the black pieces with the
this bishop pair even if black wins this
pawn on e4 the bishops are going to be
a force to be reckoned with but a pawn
is a pawn
and black has a really nice target in
this line
now sam didn't like something about this
so he played perhaps an
even simpler way with bishop f6 just
trading off
white's dark squared bishop and going
for more or less total equality
in the game bishop takes f6 was played
knight takes f6 and as i said now the
downside is
white does get to play this move e5 with
this extra central
space here and that's how white is going
to claim
to uh to have anything to to really play
for
now knight d5 was played in the game and
the move
queen d4 was actually white's choice
there are a variety
of moves here that white can try even c4
is worth considering trying to break up
these black pawns
the move queen g3 is perfectly fine just
taking a slower approach defending this
pawn
opening up h4 for the knight moves like
knight d4 could also come on the board
with a little bit of pressure
on these squares but queen d4 played in
the game
and now black actually has a really
interesting way here
to immediately equalize and perhaps even
claim a slight advantage so i'll let you
guys at home to try and find
black's next move it's a really fun move
actually i'll be impressed if you guys
can uh
find it um because it's yeah
it's a pretty it's a pretty crazy move
it's understandable why sam didn't see
it in the game
uh i think if he did see it he probably
would have played it uh because it is
actually just i think a good move but
wasn't played in the game so see if you
can find what sam shankland
could not
um and yeah the problem with g4 i think
in any position for white is that this
f4 square just ends up being a little
bit
too weak you kind of need this pawn back
here to uh guard the square
and then this diagonal isn't actually
always going to stay closed for
forever and ever thought sam was a super
gm
uh yeah he kind of is this game is a
little bit old
it's from 2013. so uh
perhaps he just hadn't reached his prime
yet perhaps as a super gm he would have
found the move
ah so toblerone actually has the answer
here
as does tarak nate says rick d8
congratulations nate you're playing like
sam shankland
uh which is pretty good uh and rook d8
might actually be a perfectly
it's also a perfectly fine move here for
black black is just doing fine but the
move c5
is really fun the point being if queen
takes d5
well now rook d8 and this queen actually
has no squares
actually just has zero squares that is a
trapped queen
so the move queen d2 would likely have
to be played and then a simple move like
knight p6 is is going for this move c4
to follow and probably this is
some kind of a quality here just some
kind of a quality white might break
through with e6
but then c4 you can expect takes and
takes with one of these pieces let's say
well let's say bishop seems more natural
bishop c2 bishop d5 and
white has a little bit of pressure over
here black has a little bit of extra
space over here
but at the end of the day all the rooks
are going to come off on these open
files
and it's it's just going to be going to
be equality
in the game though rook d8 was played
queen c5 by
white and now queen b6 was a sam's reply
queen takes b6 a takes b6 and now with
queens off the board
white still tries to prove a little
something with this knight here but now
c5 is sam's response to knight d4
and if knight takes b5 came on the board
well there's
a slightly uncomfortable fork here and
this is actually playable
for white due to the move c4 but once
again
not going to be anything more than a
quality here
so instead though knight c6 comes on the
board and
sam finds the nice move here c4 to
stay in the game if he didn't have c4 i
think sam is honestly just losing
because there's no way to stop this
annoying
threat by white so the move c4
by sam shankland now knight takes d8
comes on the board
and c takes b3 uh and fortunately
for uh uh for black here if
white tries to save this knight well now
b takes a2 is going to be really really
strong
rook a1 bishop b1 and this is not really
the end game
that uh that white is hoping for uh to
be 100
honest so instead of knight c6 uh
a takes b3 was played rook takes d8 and
now
sam actually ends up in a slightly worse
uh pawn down end game
uh where he has a knight and a bishop
for for the pawn and the rooks are are
going to be pretty good here
we see rook d1 bishop c2 c4
is white's choice and sam simply gives
back
the pieces and gets
into this pawn down end game which he
held with
ease being the strong grandmaster that
he is he simply gets active with this
rook
makes some threats on this side of the
board
and starts pushing his own pawns over
here
and this is a very fun end game but
fortunately for you guys
it's not an endgames class it is an
openings class so we'll just play
through these moves pretty quickly here
and here the players just agreed to
a draw with the black king being a
superstar blockading these two
white pawns so this was a pretty
interesting game
by these two players i think this was
more or less the critical line to look
at here
in this opening variation just to recap
slightly before moving on
of course we're looking at the fantasy
variation if you want
perhaps the most solid way of playing
the move e6 is
very very comfortable for black but it's
not really in the style of the cairo
so if you want to play like a karo
player take c4 take c4
e5 now knight f3 and we get this bishop
out to g4
these moves are all more or less forced
bishop c4 knight d7 castles knight gf6
c3 bishop d6 once again strong point
defense here
on the d6 square bishop g5 black
castles knight bd2 queen c7 really going
after this square
and now i'm going to claim really the
only real try for
white here is to go queen e1 and queen
h4 as we saw in the game
just a brief mention if moves like queen
c2 start coming on the board
that's really when things like the c5
break start to be
considerable for uh for black
for example the move b5 could come on
the board bishop d3
a6 h3 for example takes takes
and now even the move c5 and it's these
kinds of breaks
that uh find a quality for uh for black
here
so always keep in mind the c5 break if
your opponent isn't putting on the
utmost pressure
uh on you as michaelo did in this game i
cannot say that name i apologize so
queen e1 puts the most pressure on black
and doesn't really allow black time for
these c5 breaks in a lot of the cases
so bishop h5 queen h4 bishop g6 is the
big reroute for sam
now after king h1 rook e8 rook ae1
b5 bishop b3 this is where sam chose to
play this nice move knight h5
which uh i like the move c5 pretty much
just as much but knight h5
is perhaps a little bit simpler equality
for black
the move d takes e5 came on the board
knight takes e5
takes takes knight f3
uh and then here is really where i think
sam might have given his opponent a bit
too much i like the move a5
with the point that after takes and
takes black has a really comfortable
position with pressure against the e
pawn
instead though bishop f6 gives white a
little bit extra central space
and queen d4 probably wasn't the best
way to make use of it once again
probably just sitting on the space or
playing one of these
natural moves was a better way of
playing for uh
four white here but in the end sam
finds uh finds the draw on end game and
manages to draw i think
the reason he got into this worst end
game was really because of this smooth
bishop f6
so uh my claim is a5 total equality here
for black nothing to worry about okay
let's move on for queenie one line how
do we push
for more than equality with black
well you don't really often push for
more than equality with black out of the
opening
i say equality i don't mean that
that's the end of the game um there's
definitely a lot of chess left to be
played in all of these lines
but uh you can't really push for more
than equality with with the black pieces
out of the opening
you just want in equal position with
some imbalances
uh uh with with things to play for in
this case it was that target on e4 but
let's
go ahead and move on uh now i want to
take a look
at for our main variation a game between
epson lee and oystein whole
maybe hole i don't know how to say these
names i only speak
english i apologize and the point of
this line
these two players aren't quite as strong
as the players in
the previous game i just wanted to show
off a few move order tricks
from white that you're going to have to
be aware of and ways you can kind of
respond to them
so e4 c6 d4 d5 f3
we get into our main variation here
knight f3 bishop g4
bishop c4 knight d7 and then
instead of the main move in this game
white tried this move
c3 so who sees white's
threat here who sees white's threat what
if we simply play
our normal move knight gf6
what is white going to play now
what does white play now
uh jeremiah parker i think it's just
youtube uh youtube has an auto
captioning system i think
sitbon has the answer it is queen b3
this is the threat
that white made with c3 before castles
now
you're going to face pressure on both f7
and b7
it's actually quite awkward for black to
deal with and i think white would have a
substantial advantage
if the game continued in this manner so
perhaps c3 is a slightly more accurate
move order for white the good news is
for black is that we can solve these
problems with
useful moves there's really two main
options here that i'm going to recommend
one option is to play the move b5
kicking this bishop away of course
negates this threat immediately the
option i'm going to recommend though is
simply bishop h5
and you've already seen why this is a
useful move in the main variations where
this
white queen comes out to h4 we often
reroute this bishop back to g6 anyways
and so from h5 we guard this f7 square
now the move queen b3 is is quite simply
just a little bit pointless now
from white the move b5 could come the
move queen c7 could come
black can really play anything here and
life is going to be fine just as long as
you don't hang your b7 pawn
in this case it is worth not hanging i
do want to mention
you guys might have a question this is
the first game that we looked at
so why can't white play queen b3 here
the answer is
white definitely can but black will
simply castle
and now this is one of those cases where
the b7 pawn
is a little bit more trouble than it's
worth the engine actually gives it as
uh over minus one here for black uh it's
just
simply going to be bad for white to
spend so much time to take this pawn
uh just as an example line rook b8 queen
a6
e takes d4 c takes d4 um and already you
can consider capturing your pawn back
here
on e4 uh i think this line is a bit
better though taking off
this piece first now for example if
queen takes c6 knight df6 will come and
the black pieces are kind of totally
dominating in the center
it's true that white has one extra pawn
for the moment
but all of the white pieces are are
really going to be misplaced
moves like rick's theater coming and
black is is doing
actually fantastic here so that's why in
the main variation
we're not as worried about queen v3 as
we simply respond to it with castles
and then the b7 pawn isn't so important
but with c3 first we don't
quite have the time to solve our
problems so comfortably
so that's when this move bishop h5 kind
of comes in
now castles from white knight gf6 bishop
d
g5 bishop d6 knight bd2 castles queen e1
queen c7 this is stuff we've all really
seen before
d takes e5 uh okay and so then this is
the point
of the second game as well in the
previous games
we are the one previous game we saw
queen h4 here
when bishop g6 was played and with these
moves inserted
white black already had some nice
pressure on the e4 pawn
so a natural question to ask is what if
white captures on e5 first
now in those other lens that i was
showing it was
pretty common for me to play the move
knight takes f knight takes e5
keeping this bishop here on d6 and
allowing bishop takes f6 and g takes f6
and you can play like this here but i
don't think it's quite as good
as when the queen is already committed
to h4
note that some natural moves there for
white even include the move
queen g3 in some cases getting this
queen off of h4
so knight h4 to f5 doesn't come as fast
now of course the h4 square is clear so
these moves like knight h4
a little bit quicker for white so i'm
going to recommend the move
bishop takes e5 instead as was played in
this game
so if white isn't putting a super ton of
pressure
on f6 already and takes on e5
a little bit early generally the move
i'm recommending is bishop takes e5 and
that's that's going to be the case
uh specifically here as well so knight
takes e5 played in the game queen takes
e5
of course we're not really interested in
allowing bishop takes f6 stuff here
so queen takes e5 in this game the move
rick f5 came on the board
to kick this queen away the queen simply
drops back to c7
note that the move e5 here would
actually just be a little bit
premature moves like rook fe-8 come on
the board and it's pretty difficult now
for white to keep a hold of this e5 pawn
for example queen h4 on pins but now
rook takes e5 is is going to be
perfectly fine for uh for black
so instead of e5 queen h4 was played in
the game first
avoiding some of those lines but now the
move bishop g6 was played in the game
uh bishop g6 though is actually a little
bit of an inaccuracy here
let's see if you guys can take what you
learned from the sam shankland game
some moves that white played that were
perhaps necessary
and find the advantage for black in this
position black can
actually just get a pretty significant
advantage here
so we play for draw with the karo not
the case
hashim we actually play chess
with the caro generally the way openings
work
as some other people are saying in the
chat is you don't play for a draw you
play for equality with black this is the
point of the opening
phase of the game there are more phases
to the game than the opening so you play
to equalize
with black and then after you've
equalized then you're on level footing
with your opponent
to play chess and that's where you can
try to outplay them
to play for the win now some lines and
every opening are going to be more
imbalanced than others
some lines are going to look more josh
than others but uh
it's just down down to the game down to
the game of chess
so yeah everybody in the chat seems to
have it now due to the fact that white
has left this king on g1
the move queen v6 would have been quite
nice here for
black picking up the b2 pawn in some
order
instead though bishop g6 and now white
plays this move rec f2
trying to dodge perhaps that exact
threat
this is still a pretty nice position
though for black we just have
comfortable pressure
on this e4 pawn and this is why
white usually doesn't take on e5 quite
so early
basically my understanding of the
position is if
white takes on e5 and opens up this e
file
and ends up with the pawn being stuck on
e4
it's going to be a pretty good position
for black however
if white does manage to push this pawn
to e5 then it is
quite sensible for white to take on e5
because with these open lines with this
extra space with threats of e6
white does have plenty to play for now
using this e-pawn as more of an
advantage
than a liability on e4 i'm kind of
claiming this e pawn
is just strictly a liability for white
so because of that black is a nice
position we see 95 in this game
was an interesting try perhaps not
totally required
i prefer the classic plan of just
expanding over here on the queen side
not really giving white the counter play
with bishop takes f6
and this would be perfectly fine for
black
instead though knight e5 goes for some
more imbalances
we see takes and takes once again
taking on f6 isn't really advisable
if you take with the queen there is a
fork and if you take with the rook
one now queen b6 check comes on the
board again
and perhaps not even takes on a
on b2 immediately but the queen's just
in good position
and there's threats to the white pieces
so instead
bishop e2 saves this bishop from the
threat of capture now rook d8
threatens this knight knight back to f3
we see knight takes f3 bishop takes f3
queen e5 and once again the the game is
now
really in in black's hands here black is
just applying pressure to this e4 pawn
and white is kind of in a more reactive
kind of state not really creating
white's own threats rather
responding to blacks threats and and
just having to defend this e4 pawn so
rookie 2
rook d3 played in the game and i'll
quickly show you the rest of the game
it really does just revolve around this
e4 pawn we see king g7
queen d6 c5 black expands a little bit
over here
keeps an eye on his weakness uh and
after h5
uh we have loaded our alakins gun on e4
g4 was required to stop f5 and now we
see
h4 and finally black expands over here
on the queen side
creating more threats e4 gets traded for
h4 and at the end of the day
black just had a very nice end game up
upon and did
manage to win
did manage to win eventually uh white
went ahead and resigned here so the
point of this game that i wanted to get
across
is this early c3 you do have to be on
the lookout for this early c3
i recommend this move bishop h5 b5 is
also a perfectly fine way of playing
in response to this and beyond that
i wanted to show what happens when white
takes on e5 a little bit earlier than we
saw in the sam shankland
game and the reason uh you don't often
see this
is because this e4 pawn does end up
being a bit of a liability
as i said now i wanted to take a look at
one more
interesting kind of line here uh in this
last game
between uh gil popilski and hikaru
nakamura nakamura perhaps the player
you've heard of before
now in this game we're going to see
white actually adopt a slightly
different
setup to what we saw earlier and
you know i spent a normal amount of time
preparing the lecture for
for these first two games you know i
already had a pretty good feeling
of those structures and i was just
getting some specifics down
uh but then this line kind of surprised
me with how crucial it actually or how
critical it actually is white does
create
some pretty nasty threats for black to
deal with so i definitely think it's
worth covering
and if you play against the carrot with
the white pieces often
and are looking for a line perhaps you
could consider this one in the fantasy
variation because
it's one that i wasn't super familiar
with and it's it's one that does seem to
actually be
perfectly playable for white and does
cause blacks and problems so let's
take a look at it with these remaining
few minutes d4 d5 f3 takes takes e5
knight f3 bishop g4 we do see c3 now
for white a slightly different move
order from what we looked at
we don't have to play bishop h5 yet
because bishop c4 isn't on the board
so white isn't threatening to fork these
pawns just yet so
knight d7 comes on the board now of
queen b3 like i said this
isn't actually a fork so we can just
kind of defend our pawn anyway we like
instead now we're going to see white
adopt a different setup as i said
in all the previous games we were
looking at bishop c4
now i want to take a look at bishop d3
and this is a very actually combative
way for white to play this opening it
looks
simply less active than bishop c4 but
what white is saying with this move
bishop d3
is that he will open this diagonal and
so he will just leave this bishop on d3
where it's going to be more active once
the diagonal opens
so this is where it becomes all the more
critical
to keep a hold of our strong point on e5
if the strong point falls then white's
going to open up this diagonal
and black could get into some trouble so
this is why i think this line is more
combative
actually than bishop c4 so bishop d6 was
ikaro nakamura's response perfectly fine
castles knight gf6 all the same moves
that we've seen from black so far
and now white plays this slightly weird
looking move a4
and the purpose behind this move is is
really
simply to prevent the move b5 now why
does white want to prevent the move b5
you know his bishop's sitting perfectly
fine
on d3 in fact it makes more sense to
prevent b5 with the bishop on c4 to
avoid losing this tempo
in this case though with the bishop on
d3 there's one more advantage
for white and it's that it's preventing
the natural setup of the black pieces
with the queen on c7 and the bishop on
d6
how is it preventing this well with the
c4 open
white actually is aiming to land a
different piece on this square and that
of course is this knight on b1
so a4 was played to keep hold of this b5
square
to keep these knight c4 threats alive
for white
now black castles we see knight bd2 uh
come on the board for white
and carol plays rookie eight a perfectly
natural move defending the strong point
on e5 making threats to e4
and now knight c4 comes on the board car
simply responds with bishop c7
which is a a totally fine move here
the problem now for black of course is
that the queen
cannot really come to this natural
square queen c2
was white's move in the game and uh
if you analyze this game as i did with
an engine
you're going to get some pretty funny
looking stuff for a little bit where the
engine thinks
that uh black is actually able to
sacrifice a piece on the e4 square
but after analyzing those lines a little
bit more in depth it turns out just to
be bad for black so so don't be fooled
by that
the line that stockfish gives is
something like bishop f3 rook f3
takes takes takes on e4 bishop takes e4
and then the move knight f6
and for a second it thinks that black is
doing quite well here with queen takes
d4
rookie 1 coming but at the end of the
day white's just up a piece and white is
just better
so don't fault for those tricks
in the game now hikaru actually plays
the move e
takes d4 giving up on this e5 pawn
and eventually just allowing in fact the
movie e5 to come on the board
now uh i don't really like this way of
playing
from hikaru nakamura uh in fact in the
game he did end up a bit
worse which is really surprising to me
because his name is karo nagamura
and his opponent's name i can't
pronounce and and you know
and less familiar with you know
generally karo nakamura is
better out of the opening against these
players so
i found that really interesting and
that's why i think this line is
pretty critical to look at the line i'm
going to recommend
after i analyzed for a lot longer than i
cared to admit
is bishop takes f3 i think this line
gives black the the best position here
you give up this light squared bishop
but in return
you loosen white's hold of the e5 square
this is kind of the principle behind it
and the specifics work out i think to be
pretty okay
for black so for example
rook takes f3 g takes f3 doesn't make a
lot of sense
for white so rook takes f3 and then the
move i'm going to recommend
is the move knight f8 simply unveiling
this threat on the d4 pawn and getting
into
some fun kind of tactics
for example if the if white wants to
play a little bit more simply a move
like king h1 can come on the board
and then there are a variety of ways of
playing here
for black for example we can try and
take this pawn off the board this is
perfectly playable
if so sorry i should say the simple way
of playing bishop e3
but then you run into the nice move
knight g4
by black and white is going to have all
the same problems anyways
so it's really actually quite difficult
for white to defend this pawn queen f2
likely going to meet the same fate of
knight g4 here
so instead white is now forced to go for
this active tri because these boring
moves don't work because d4 hangs
so white goes for the active move bishop
g5
and the line i came up with here is e
takes d4
and rather than the move c takes d4 by
white allowing queen takes d4 with check
the move e5
by white is is going to be a pretty
interesting one
and the line continues bishop takes e5
knight takes c5
rook takes e5 bishop takes f6 g takes f6
rook a to f1 and what we have now
is a really fun type of position
where white has a lot of pressure on the
king's side
but in the meantime the white center has
blown up
and black is actually up two pawns
for the moment two pawns d takes c3 for
example kind of secures this advantage
queen takes c3 and now we we really are
in
for a very fun game here where black is
up these two pawns and white has this
nice bishop
some active pieces and some threats
around the king
now i haven't analyzed this to super
super deep levels where i'm going
through all the various options from
this point forward
but if if you do run the engine for a
while as i did uh
it thinks uh equality um which is
really the the funny answer that that
the engine often gives in positions like
this
so some kind of dynamic equality here
for black from what i can tell
as far as moves for example even a move
like
king g7 is playable now if rick takes f6
we're simply going to take this back and
go in for this type of endgame position
where we have two rooks against the
queen
and if white wants to keep pieces on the
board for example
h4 well black is just going to start
organizing
the rooks on these open central files
and black
should be perfectly fine in the game and
now from what i can tell
white is actually the one who's going to
end up worse unless white immediately
goes in for these moves like rook takes
f6
going in for this uh two rooks versus
queen
end game where black does have an extra
pawn white probably should be able to be
fine in those positions as well
due to the unfortunate safety of the
black king
but of course black is not really going
to be in in too much danger there
so that's what i'm recommending in
response to this line knight c4 bishop
c7
queen c2 i like this nice move knight f8
to keep up the pressure on white's s
well sorry bishop takes f3 is required
first
to alleviate pressure on e5 and then
knight f8
with these pressure with this pressure
on white's center now in the game
hikaru nakamura played the move e takes
d4 c takes d4 bishop takes f3 rook takes
f3
and i i just don't think it makes sense
to allow white to push in the center
quite so early on
with this with these e5 brakes i think
this is
just going to ask for a little bit of
trouble here in the game hikaru
continued with knight b6
and white does immediately play this
nice move e5
and this is really giving white
everything he wanted here with this
pressure
along this open diagonal so that's why i
recommend this other line
for black and i take c4 played in the
game
queen takes c4 b5 queen c3 bishop b6
bishop e3 knight into d5 and this
is uh hikaru's compensation for allowing
the move e5 he gets this nice
d5 square for his knight queen b3 is
played in the game
b takes a4 from hikaru rick takes a4
rook b8 now
makes a threat queen c4 queen d7 from
hikaru
bishop f2 and g6 now from hikaru
and this is where i think uh white's
advantage started to dwindle a little
bit
because white was playing hikaru
nakamura and cars so far has been
playing more or less perfectly
um i think the move h4
would have actually given white a nice
edge here the point being
if you don't play h5 white will play h5
himself
and start to weaken down these king side
pawns in front of the black king start
to get
a little bit more pressure over here and
if you do play h5 well h5 itself
is in fact a concession with this g6
pawn
becoming a lot more weak after this
moves like queen c2 to follow
uh sarnath quincy three queen c2 to
follow with threats of
bishop takes g6 always going to be in
the air
and things like this would have been
really nice for white instead though
bishop e4
is a fine move but f5 by ikaru is
trying to force some pieces off the
board
bishop c2 king g7 rook fa3
now a5 by hikaru is locking things down
on this queen side and now after
especially move like king h1
black has enough time to get back into
this game comfortably bishop c7 queen a2
knight b4 uh queen c4
knight d5 queen a2 and they repeated
moves with a draw
um so this is the last line i wanted to
look at here
uh with all of these threats coming on
the board
for white so of course this is the line
with bishop d3
actually a more combative line by white
claiming he
will be able to play this move e5 at a
later date
of course what i'm recommending in
response is don't let white do that
defend your strong point on e5 take on
f3
if you have to to defend your strong
point on e5
and from there due to the way white has
played it becomes quite
awkward to defend this pawn on d4
and because of that you get some nice
threats with a move
like knight f8 in this kind of position
okay that i believe is it for me today i
will allow the youtube chat to
uh ask one or two more questions if they
have any of it before we get going here
um if uh there are no questions if
you're watching
live be sure to tune in to the twitch
channel directly after this where i will
be
teaching tactics time uh if you're
watching the recorded video
thank you very much for joining me
that's all
for tonight it's looking like
there aren't really any questions for me
in the chat hopefully
you enjoyed this lecture on the fantasy
variation of the keracon
hopefully you feel confident enough to
play it in some of your own games
um just be sure to avoid these few
tricky moves by white and then black
should be doing quite well that's all
for me
this week thank you so much for joining
me this week on chess openings explained
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you
next time
[Music]
you